hello everyone and welcome back to the
Capablanca saga we are back at the 1914
simultaneous exhibition in Buenos Aires
Argentina and here kappa blanka faces
with the black pieces which is kind of
odd I thought he would have the white
pieces in all the games but against mr.
Correa he has the black pieces and I
almost wasn't able to find a photo of
mr. Correa this is not a photo it's it's
well it's a portrait someone drew a nice
portrait of him and I almost used this
one but this is a different gentleman
it's a gentleman that died in 1897
don't don't Valentin Fernandez Correa
but this is a different different fellow
who as you can see in the court above
the board capablanca mentions that Senor
Correa is a fairly strong chess
enthusiasts but as this was his first
meeting with a front rank master he
allowed himself to be too impressed what
this means we will see in the game but
before we check out the game I have a
request to those of you who well who are
sort of fluent in Spanish we do have
some information available about mr.
Correa
about it in Spanish it's also where I
found this very nice portrait of him the
first thing you will see in the
description below is a link to that will
lead you to some information about mr.
Correa if you are a native Spanish
speaker or you understand Spanish feel
free to translate it for us and you know
just drop it down in the comment section
I will give you a hardware pin your
comments so we can all enjoy some
information about mr. Correa that being
said let's check out this very nice game
I'm sure you're gonna enjoy it as it's
just amazing
mr. Correa opens with the white pieces
and he plays efore now we have e5 Knight
to f3 Knight to c6 and now Knight to c3
Knight to f6 we have the four Knights
game and now Bishop to b5
the Spanish variation of the four
Knights Bishop to b4 couple Bunker
continues in a symmetrical fashion we
have castles castles and now d3
capablanca replies with d6 keeping
everything symmetrical and here we have
Bishop to g5 and now it's one of those
cases where if you continue just
repeating White's moves and playing
let's say Bishop to g4 you want to keep
the symmetry going then white
break the symmetry and gain a
significant advantage for example after
Bishop captures Queen captures now you
just bought Knight d5 attacking the
Queen and also the c7 pawn after the
Queen goes back now you just eliminate
the defender of the bishop on b4
captures and now you grab the bishop and
okay you didn't win a piece here black
wooden will win the piece back after a 5
the knight doesn't have anywhere to go
you have to capture on c6 and after
Queen attacks night and now both of
blacks pawns are controlling the Knights
retreat squares here white would just
have to give up in the night for for a
central pawn after pawn captures let's
say this and we basically force this
endgame Queen and rook in game where
white is up two points with a completely
intact pawn structure and black has a
well I'll ruin pawn structure and he's
down to pawn so it should be winning for
white so after Bishop to g5 of course
capablanca does not try to hold symmetry
he goes to Bishop captures on c3 not
allowing any future 95 ideas he captures
on c3 and now Queen to e7 and here rook
to e1 this was the sand standard theory
even those days but here nice the d2 by
mr. Korea and okay couple Monica goes h6
asks what do you want to do and even as
here kappa blanka suggested that not
that obviously that white should just
give up both the bishops for 4 nights
and play this material you know
materialistically equal end game where
white would have a night against the
bishop black would be slightly better
but a couple monk i thought that this
was the way to go but okay Craig was a
bishop to h4 and now Capablanca no
longer allows exchanger C goes in Knight
d8 prepares to bring this Knight over to
e6
we have d4 and now comes nice to e 6 and
now d5 is is possible if Corey are
plated but then comes a 6 Bishop d3 and
Knight to f4 word where black would have
a very nice output for his Knight
so here Korea plays D captures on e5
Capablanca agrees that this is much
needed
but it leaves the white with a with a
weak pawn structure on the Queen side so
here kappa blanka plays d captures on e5
we have mushroom back to d3 if you want
to activate the night you have to bring
an hour
defender to the the e4 pawn Knight to f4
backup Oh Blanca and now Knight to c4
and here rook to d8 and if you look at
this position now why Capablanca thought
that maybe it's just better to give up
both both of the bishops four knights
and play that endgame that we mentioned
now it's very hard to find a move here
for white there's constant pressure
against the bishop the bishop is also
pinned you can't really move it there's
no really no good move white can make
here for example if you try something
like Queen to f3
then g5 seems to be a very nice idea but
from g3 and then Bishop to g4 now
forcing the Queen to move yet again
let's say Queen e3 and now you you you
could play this position although it's
it's very unpleasant for for white so
after this
rook to d8 we have Bishop captures on f6
but here couple Blanca just says okay
you do reduce the material on the board
but on the other hand also a couple
Blanca things that this is not just a
winning position for black we have Queen
captures on f6 and now again you don't
really have a good move for white you
didn't really achieve anything by
exchanging that bishop if you try
something like Queen to have three
couple one conventions that nice to h3
check is a very nice idea of course if
you capture the night if you capture
with the Queen then Bishop captures
Queen if you capture with the pawn then
you lose the Queen very nice
and if you go King to h1 then just queen
characters would be sufficient and
Capablanca is very very confident that
you would be able to win this game now
where White has a CC pawn and a double
def born so after Queen captures on f6
Queen to d2 by mr. Korea but now
Capablanca just goes out in an all-out
attack with Bishop to h3 and it's a
wonderful idea of course you cannot
capture the bishop if you capture it
then Queen g5 or g6 doesn't matter
forces checkmate there is nothing to
block check with after King moves queen
g2 will be checkmate so after Bishop to
h3 we have night III by Y preparing
Knight to a5 and here a couple Blanca
place and Bishop captures on g2 a very
nice idea although he also mentions that
night the g2 would also be winning
because after Knight captures Queen f3
threatens checkmate
now you do have to you don't have to
move for example 9h for now you just get
twin g4 check and after the King moves
special characters an f1 rook captures
and out Queen captures on h4 leave the
black of the exchange in in a winning
position but Bishop captures is a much
more elegant and quicker so this is what
capablanca plays Bishop captures on g2
and now again you cannot capture it if
you capture Queen g5 threatens checkmate
and there's not much you can do you can
play f3 but now of course you see how
how black wins a white prevented
checkmate but nice to h3 just you know
picks up the Queen King has to go to h1
now can capture some d2 wins the Queen
so after Bishop captures on g2 Korea
attempted Knight to f5 and here there
are a lot of a lot of good moves for
black Queen g5 is a very nice move
immediately capturing and e3 is a very
nice move but Capablanca goes for the
for the tricky line he plays special
captures a need for removing the
defender of the night and f5 and now and
also putting more pressure on d3 but
there is an even greater threat which
Valentin Fernandes Korea unfortunately
for him missed he retreated wooden
night-night the g3 with a double attack
against the bishop here but here feel
free to pause the video here and try to
find the best move for black maybe some
of you even were able to do it without
pausing the video but for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
you are either an excellent
checkmater in 1 or you are an excellent
memorizer of thumbnails as I also use
this for a thumbnail but the correct
move is Knight to h3 for those who just
want to enjoy the show and this is now
checkmate as the bishop controls this
diagonal it's check and the King has
nowhere to go
yeah just just a wonderful attacking
attacking game by Capablanca now you see
what complain comment by by this that
he's a fairly strong chess enthusiasts
but as this was his first meeting with a
front rank master he allowed himself to
be too impressed and then played you
know on a few occasions continued just
poorly like we've seen in the previous
game there was no reason that rook h2 f8
you know wasn't played for a couple long
as opponent just doubled rooks and
e-file for some reason and then cover
Lanka just created this wonderful
initiative which one in the game game in
the end but here you can see it's it's
not like today when grandmasters have
like simultaneous exhibitions today they
play against weaker opponents and they
just so you know crush everyone maybe
there's like a draw there but here you
can see that every opponent of
capablanca who was a very strong player
especially a player like Prokofiev for
example who even worn a game against
capablanca but yeah yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it and that you
are enjoying my coverage of the
capablanca saga so far if you haven't
been following me from the beginning the
second link in the description below
will take you to all the videos that are
so far included in the cover longer saga
and once again for those of you who are
native to Spanish language feel free to
check out the first link in the
description and you know if you feel
like it translated for the rest of us so
we can also also enjoy a little bit more
information about mr. Valentin Fernandez
Korea I would like to thank Raymond
young a understand which is silly in the
SHINee Guilherme Albert and Andres
Martin for the contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check -
on my previous videos here think all for
watching and I will see you soon
continue in the capo Blanca saga
checking up on your suggestions and
doing what we usually do here I think
you all have an excellent weekend and I
will see you soon